So, one of things when I was learning how to program was casting. And that was
something that [LAUGH]
I feel like I learned casting a little bit later than everyone else because its
just that it was very foreign for me to really understand like how everything
was set up initially. And so when I learned about like you know oh I have
variables. I got that. Okay? So, there's variables. But then you know, you've
got ints you've got doubles, and that, that was one of those things I didn't
understand the importance of it. And for a while I kind of dismissed it as like
I don't want to ask for help, like it's okay. Like I'm just going to, I'm just
going to go right through this, and then I'd have problems where I'd be running
my code. And then like all of a sudden I got a crazy long number back and I'm
like what did I do wrong? The person next to me just got six. How did I had,
how did I mess up here? And the email was one of the thing that's like, I think
my pride was a little bit got in the way, I probably should have just like,
hey, why isn't my number working? By the time I understood, like the difference
it's like a whole number versus like you know, number of the decimal like the
know like oh, I get it, like. Now, it's just, like, instinctive. Like, whenever
I'm, you know, writing something, like, I know which number like, what kind of
custom I have with it. And it's those little things that, like, they kind of
stand in the way, at first, where it's, it's silly looking back but, I mean
once you get the, like major concepts down. It's like, you wouldn't even think
twice about it. It's like, I've got a hand and well, I've got an int. [LAUGH]